Encuentra la pendiente de una recta perpendicular
a la recta "3x" más "2y" igual a 6.
Entonces, si yo tengo una línea...
hagamos unos ejes aquí, ese es mi eje "y"
y ese es mi eje "x" y supongamos que tengo
una recta aquí, que tiene una pendiente "m".
Así es que la pendiente de esta
recta es igual a "m".
Y una recta que sea perpendicular a esta,
va a ser una recta que la va a intersectar
en un ángulo de 90 grados.
Así es que esto se va a ver así, esta es
la recta perpendicular
y este es un ángulo de 90 grados.
Y la pendiente de esta recta, no lo voy a
probar aquí, lo haré en otro video,
pero la pendiente de esta recta va a ser igual
a menos el recíproco de la pendiente de la
recta original, es decir, esta
pendiente es igual a -1 entre
la pendiente de la recta original, es decir -1 entre "m".
Habiendo establecido esto, si podemos calcular
cual es la pendiente de esta recta,
simplemente calcularemos el negativo
del recíproco de esa pendiente
y tendremos la pendiente de la recta perpendicular.
Calculemos entonces,
la pendiente de esta recta.
Escribamos la ecuación aquí y la manera
más fácil de hacer esto es despejar "y",
para llevar la ecuación a la forma "y" igual
a "mx" más "b"
y determinar por inspección cual
es el valor de la pendiente.
Eliminemos entonces las "x" del lado izquierdo.
Restamos "-3x" a ambos lados...
restamos "-3x" a ambos lados y del lado izquierdo los términos en "x"desaparecen,
me queda "2y" y del lado
derecho me queda,  menos "3x" más 6.
Ahora, dividimos entre 2 ambos lados de la
ecuación, dividimos entre 2,
en este caso ambos términos del lado derecho y nos queda, "y" igual a -3/2 de "x",
este término de aquí es -3/2 más 3.
Entonces la pendiente de la
recta que nos dieron,
esa pendiente la podemos identificar fácilmente ahora que hemos llevado la ecuación
A la forma pendiente ordenada.
Y es igual a -3/2, esa es la pendiente.
Así es que, la pendiente de la recta perpendicular
a ésta, va a ser el negativo del recíproco
de este valor, así que el negativo de un
valor negativo va a ser positivo y el recíproco
de 3/2 va a ser igual a 2/3, así que el negativo
del recíproco de -3/2 es 2/3 positivo.
Y hemos concluido, ésta es la pendiente de
una recta que es perpendicular a esta recta de aquí.